PEGI 18
how's it going I'm samster Ackman
narrative designer EV tsov Paris the
studio behind Ghost Recon wildlands as
you know our goal is to create a
realistic and modern shooter in a
massive open world recently we've been
sharing the vision of our game with a
couple of our friends the guys over Red
Storm entertainment creators of the very
first ghost recon game as well as a
special guest we're very excited to give
you a first glimpse into that creative
process I hope you enjoy
Ghost Recon was we had just worked on
Rainbow six rogue spear at sequel and
wanted to do something a little
different take it wide open into a big
world and see what you can do in those
wide open spaces we wanted to show
players what it would be like to be a
covert American warfighter at the tip of
the spear in the modern battlefield it's
not run and gun it's about getting into
position reconning your environment and
deciding how you want to approach the
problem you do need to think but you
also need to react and for me that's
where the excitement comes in it is the
ideal shooter one of the philosophies
with authenticity and the Tom Clancy
games is to learn what's real and then
extrapolate from that to make the best
game experience possible we want gear
and equipment to be correct we want
tactics to be correct we want enemy
reactions to be reasonable we want the
environments to look real we have access
to so many experts people who are in the
field and they're here to tell us their
stories so we've have always had a
really broad range of people that we
could draw up on the list is long
because again because we are authentic
we are appreciated by a lot in the
military that do do this and so they
like to help to make sure we continue to
get it right over the past several years
at Ubisoft Paris we've done a tremendous
amount of research to create a coherent
and authentic world our starting point
was the Tom Clancy universe but we also
worked with a number of experts on drug
cartels like drug enforcement officers
who introduced us to some real-life
smugglers we did training exercises with
guys and special operations and Special
Forces we spend time exploring Bolivia
we even went to the CIA headquarters and
got advice from officers who are working
in South America all the hours and hours
of research that the team has been doing
and literally be seen on screen bolivia
and Ghost Recon wildlands feels like a
living breathing place
and Ubisoft Paris our goal is to
maintain the authenticity of the
universe while bringing new elements to
Ghost Recon a living breathing open
world vehicles for land air and water
four player co-op the hot joint feature
a non linear progression so that every
player is creating their own unique
experience it's very true to the the
core principles of those free gun at the
same time it's just a fantastic
expansion I'm actually very impressed
with what I saw looking at a version of
the game I know it's still early in
production but I personally am excited
because it looks like the game that we
always wanted to make I think the level
of detail that's there and again this is
early production I was just really
impressed with quality the visuals it
doesn't just feel like ghost recon but
it feels like it delivers on the truth
on the original kind of promise of the
ghost recon of being out there as a
soldier in a small army fighting a war
you know not just some guys going
through just linear missions it's what
ghost recon was meant to be I can't wait
to hear what people think of this game
and not just from an authenticity
perspective I mean I cannot wait to hear
the crazy stories and insane events that
come out of people taking this systemic
world and making things happen that
nobody expected I hope you enjoyed this
video and we look forward to giving you
more information about the game until
then keep it on ghost recon calm join
the conversation on the official forms
and sub right talk to you later
[Music]
[Music]
you